[Music]
good afternoon welcome to the first sog
podcast actually according to jocko
willink our sponsor for this new
endeavor
it will be called sog cast
so what is sag sog was during the
vietnam war
an eight-year secret war that was
conducted during the entire vietnam war
from 1964 to 1972
during that time there were misses that
were run
where soldiers the green berets who
participated in those missions
signed documents saying it would never
talk about it
now 50 years later
we're allowed to talk about it and
thanks to jocko willink
and his production company we are now
going forward with a new
episode
and going forward with the stories about
sog
today i'm joined by a longtime friend of
mine a fellow recon man
george sternberg
who we served together at fob-1 fubai in
1968
and george welcome to the show our
historic first song cast sir thank you
very much mr myers glad to have you here
and with our podcast
we have basically
interviewing veterans and with jocko
there have been 10 sog podcasts in the
past
where he conducted the interviews my
name is john striker meyer nicknamed
tilt i've had the honor of being on
several of jaco's actually eight
podcasts with him
where we've reviewed the stories
that are now
being podcast through his different
social medias at the end of this show
we'll refer to those and mention them
and with george joining us today
thank you for coming in
and
i'd like to
go to an early story to give you a
little bit of a sense of what some of
the sog missions were like and in this
particular case
it was in may 1968
george was a member of the recon team at
that time they were called spike teams
he was on spike team oregon
with the team leader mike tucker and a
fellow team member
mike perry steve steve perry thank you
very much
and
at that time we'd had one of our recon
teams spike team idaho
had disappeared it was put into a target
and the team had literally disappeared
in layoffs
so the following day or two days
afterward
spike team oregon
went into
that target area to find out what
happened to st idaho
and i'm going to turn to the book across
the fence
for a few paragraphs about that mission
where george participated with that
after the long flight across south
vietnam
the king bees inserted st oregon
on the same lz
where s t idaho had been inserted
a small hill
near a bomb crater
from the lz
st oregon's point man
found
idaho's trail
through grass
only a foot or two tall
the trail led down the hill
within minutes
team members heard nva
in several locations
hitting sticks together
in an effort to force the team
to move in a certain direction
at first
sternberg hoped the nba were beating the
sticks
in an effort to get oregon and idaho
to move in a certain direction
they followed s t idaho's tracks
indirectly
through the grass and down the hill
ha
sternberg and tucker knew
that lane the team leader of st idaho
often planted little anti-personnel
mines called tow poppers
to hurt nva trackers
and to give his team warning of enemy
activity on their trail
because the vegetation was thin
the team increased the distance between
team members
tucker so soon saw an nba flag on a post
in the ground
sternberg observed a large road at the
bottom of the hill and an empty guard
booth
perry
saw the guard booth and realized this
was a road heavily traveled by nva
and pathet lao troops
across the road tucker saw more than a
dozen armed nba soldiers heading towards
them
but they were unaware of st oregon's
exact location
team members heard several trucks in the
distance moving in their direction
tucker wasted no time
he ordered the team back to the bomb
crater
while signaling sternberg to radio covey
to report the enemy activity
and the need for attack air
asap
tucker wanted to keep the high ground
advantage as long as possible
there was no question about it
the nba knew another spike team was in
the area
and it was only a matter of minutes
before oregon would be fighting for its
life
sternberg pulled out his irk 10
emergency radio
and immediately made contact with air
assets in the area
as st oregon moved into the bomb crater
several nba soldiers opened fire on the
team
sternberg felt like he was in the middle
of an old tv western
as the nva rounds kicked up the dirt
around him
the nba fuselage incredible increased in
ferocity and the entire team suddenly
realized
that among the weapons being fired at
them were cult car 15s
weapons only carried by cnc spike teams
the nba soldiers were now close enough
to throw hand grenades into the large
bomb crater
the team was spread around the lip of
the crater
fending off attacks
suddenly three or four nva soldiers ran
down the incline straight toward st
oregon firing on full automatics
sternberg thought several of the nva
were high on some sort of drug
because even after he shot one of them
twice
the momentum of the soldier's body
continued to carry him toward the team
before collapsing
another nva charged toward sternberg
carrying grenades
as the enemy soldier started to throw a
grenade
the ohio native opened fire with his car
15.
the rounds slammed into the nba's body
carrying out
huge chunks of flesh and shredding his
uniform
but somehow
the enemy soldier continued his forward
movement
more important he threw the grenade
it was an american
m-26 frag grenade
sternberg grabbed the grenade and threw
it towards several charging nva
several more chai com
chinese communist grenades
were hurled into the crater
but most of them failed to detonate
the ones that did explode caused minimal
damage to team members
meanwhile sternberg directed several
airstrikes by air force f-4 phantom jets
between the bomb crater and the road
then the single prop a1 skyraider
strafed above the crater where more nva
soldiers were firing down on st oregon
the sky raiders first gun runs were so
close
sternberg could count the rivets on the
warplane
when the skyraiders wingmen followed
with a second gun run
tucker and sternberg watched in awe
as the 20 mike mike cannons instantly
shredded the woodline
and all the nva in it
the gun run left sternberg covered with
dirt wood chips and leaves
he handled his sawed-off m79 grenade
launcher to one of his chinese nung
members
nicknamed monkey
the nung fired his m-79 into the air
using the 40 millimeter high explosive
round as small mortar fire
while using sternberg's m79 to fire
directly into charging nva soldiers
another nva charged the bomb crater and
threw an m26 hand grenade towards the
team
to steve perry's horror
he saw the m26 sail into the bomb crater
and land a short distance from his feet
the sf medic was applying a bandage to
one of st oregon's nungs
who had been shot in the calf by an
ak-47 round
as he moved to protect the nung
the m26 exploded
killing the young vietnamese lieutenant
who was on the other side of the bomb
crater
it blew the jungle boots off steve perry
and peppered him and several team
members with hot shrapnel
sternberg got hit in the leg hip
elbow and head
shrapnel shred one of his jungle boots
the power of the m26 explosion left
perry with no feeling from his shoulders
down
he feared the shrapnel had caused a
spinal column injury
through the den
tucker quickly inspected perry's back
for wounds or bleeding and found none
the impact of the explosion had
temporarily stunned perry
still he was amazed to be alive
and that is just one of the first
chapters from across defense
where
as jacob would say
the stories are just amazing and
sometimes
beyond belief i'm biased we were all
there together
but george
you were there that day in that crater
yes i was
excuse me that's all right
and uh so talk to us a little bit
because at that point when that hand
grenade went off
your jungle boots are shredded yeah i
lost both soles off of both boots and it
it was almost like somebody took a razor
knife
and drug it across my feet the bottom of
them
but i didn't feel it
uh at one point when that grenade
come close to steve
i had my fingertips on it
and it fell in a little bit of water
underneath the uh
in the bottom of the bomb crater and i
couldn't find it and at that instant
my buddy mike tucker reached down
grabbed me by the collar
and pulled me up into
the ridge of the the top of the bomb
crater
and then
once we started to get air assets in
and
the chopper ended up coming down
to extract us
steve was stunned he couldn't even move
he was paralyzed
and
we had to find a way to get him out
and as soon as that chopper put its
wheel down
i grabbed him picked him up
and ran out of bomb crater and put him
on the chopper
and so before that so how deep was the
crater from the top down to the bottom
because i'd have to i'd have to
just estimate but that's good enough 53
years later i could stand up
in the bottom
and i still wouldn't be out and i'm only
5'4
so i would have to say it was pretty
close to seven eight foot deep
yeah in a tapered situation yes sir
so
during that firefight um before the
helicopter which in this case was a
south vietnamese air force from the
219th
that came into to pick up the team under
extreme fire
um how long
were you actually engaged with the nva
from that first fire opening of the fire
fight with you
and then shooting at the nva charging
your your bomb creator uh well we were
when that first chopper landed we were
had been
out of the crater for
probably 20 minutes
from the time we got on the ground
and we had spotted a couple flags
like flags nva flags nva flags when i
flew in
um
the north or the south vietnamese pilots
or the king bees have a tendency to roll
them they look like you're going to fall
out the door
and it was a beautiful maneuver always
helped us
the spiral when it was firing spy rolled
in and then as they turned to put that
wheel down the final flare yep they
rolled them and it was almost like uh
almost like 180 degrees and they'd flip
it and it always screwed up
the north vietnamese they didn't think
they could do it
and
when that happened
uh
out the window
opposite the door
i seen a flag on a flagpole
and mike's seen it too but he didn't
think how big it was well
it was pretty good size
and i just tapped him on his shoulder
and i said
we're in trouble
and we no sooner hit the ground
now we took fire going in
but it wasn't real heavy it was just
enough that the pilot said
right so under ordinary circumstances
when you're on a recon team
a sog recon team you're getting inserted
into layoffs or cambodia or north
vietnam
if you're on a regular mission and you
took enemy gunfire you would not
continue
no
i think the
the way of the bright light was the
bright light was different
because you're going in after your
fellow
recon team members and then on a bright
light because it was different
um
you could explain just a little bit
about how you carried more bullets
weapons we carried i
i was 112 pounds but i carried them
soaking wet
soaking wet
i carried the radio
i carried an irk10 radio
a high frequency
i carried
20 magazines
i carried um
about 15
of the
new baseball grenades which were the
26s
and uh
i also carried my other weapons and the
f-79 sawdust
the right sawed-off i had some for shot
rounds in it
um and some grenades how many hand
grenades uh i had anywhere from probably
14 15 16 grenade
and i carried
um
anywhere from 5 to 10 pounds of c4 with
blasting caps and stuff like this just
in case we run into an opportunity to
tear some stuff up
but uh
it probably
pretty close to doubled my weight
but i
i've always been in good
physical condition so that never
bothered me
and then um
with that hand grenade went off that was
like a really a major turning point for
that brief time on the ground
your jungle i mean to think about jungle
boots that have they were constructed
with metal plates on the bottom
the hand grenade to have the force to
blow or shred yours and then blow steve
perry's boots off while
making him basically feel paralyzed at
least momentarily he was he he was
paralyzed clear until they till the
chopper got him to the hospital
you know and he still couldn't walk he
couldn't walk he couldn't
uh twist his body
uh he could move a little bit on his
hands
and his head but
other than that he couldn't get out of
the bomb crater
all right then that's i just want to go
back to another uh paragraph from the
book just that
i to this day 53 years later i remember
hearing about was over the radio in
front of the master and sergeant major's
office in the radio room at fob1 yes sir
by now several team members were wounded
from hand grenade shrapnel or ak-47
gunfire
the fact that the shrapnel was from u.s
grenades
led to the general assumption that the
nba
had killed st idaho
and st idaho had the 1-0 glenn lane the
1-1 was robin owen and they had four or
six indigenous troops with him six of
them were six all the total team was all
eight all together right
and
that
sergeant lane was an experienced 1-0
and sergeant owen was returning the
country for another tour of duty as a
green beret
so they had a lot of experience as well
as the indigenous people on the team
and
so tucker directed a few more close air
strikes sternberg's irk10 emergency
radio stopped working
he stuffed the dead battery in his chest
pocket
and slammed a new one into the radio
then the nba lobbed mortar rounds toward
the bomb crater
sternberg was pissed because he knew he
couldn't catch a mortar shell and throw
it back
shortly the nva mortimen began to
bracket the mom crater with incoming
rounds
as the mortar rounds marched toward the
crater
tucker directed scarface to execute
strafing runs
right behind the gunships the first king
bee landed to pick up the most seriously
wounded members of st oregon
sternberg
perry hall and the most seriously
wounded nung
boarded the first kingby
which quickly lifted off from the lz
the second king be landed to pick up the
remainder of the battered team
as the remainder of st oregon boarded
the second king b
sternberg's chopper circled the lz to
observe
when the aircraft cleared the lz
the first king be circled close enough
that sternberg and other team members
fired their car 15s and m-79s down at
the nva
an enemy bullet ripped through the
kingby's thin metal wall
lifted sternberg from the window and
drove him across the floor
of the h-34
and again here for our audience we
should explain that the h-34
was an older helicopter
it had a single door on the right side
and then inside
there were windows on the left side two
windows and a window on the right and
whenever a team got on they would fire
out both windows
to support the helicopter and try to
suppress enemy gunfire
and the pilots were above but the
passengers were in the lower part of the
compartment and so you were by the
window and around hit sternberg
in the chest
i mean
as jacques would say i'm amazed you're
still alive sir
um
go ahead so from that point so
after being the bomb creator you're
giving support fire you just catch a
round in the chest
that moment in time what what happened
was um
as we were firing you could see
groups moving
larger groups moving through the area
and they were headed
to to the bomb crater so we knew if we
didn't get out of there soon
we'd all be history and the chance and
then at that
point if we didn't keep
suppressing
and returning fire on them
they would just increase and increase
and increase and we wouldn't even get
out with the choppers
right
so you know at that point when i got hit
it actually picked me up
and i'm moving across toward the doorway
well the doorway the only person sitting
in it is on the left side
and that's the vietnamese door gunner
with a 30 caliber
machine gun he's firing away full blast
he was going full blast and
the point man monkey that was the
smallest he was like me
he put his arm out
and then
i think it was mike it had to be mike
no it was uh
our tail gunner bow
grabbed me by the pants
at the belt line
and held me
or i'd have been out thousand foot maybe
out the door oh my god
and all that did
was i kept the battery pack
and
i buried it in my
rucksack when i came home
and
maybe 3 8 of an inch
out of the back of out of the back of
the
uh battery pack it had
just barely pierced the skin that
created blood
and it
cracked two ribs
is that right and that's it
you know
and and it's amazing
even that a thousand foot or more
and coming through the thin skin that
they had on these choppers
that it didn't go all the way through me
you know
and already having several wounds
you know i didn't even think about it
yeah i just
well some might argue that your skin was
so thick by that time you're so tough
that uh
yeah that could be
but let me get back to the book here
because uh this is
mind-boggling for me too even 53 years
later
sternberg sat on the floor amid the
hydraulic fluids that were leaking from
the kingby
he was too stunned to move as several
more enemy rounds ripped through the
chopper
ordinarily as the common man on the st
sternberg would have radioed cubby on
the prc or the york 10.
and again on er 10 could you just
describe a little bit of how this radio
is it's only a handheld is small and
then that battery that saved your life
was how thick
not very no
yeah and it slipped into the back so the
rate would be like five inches tall
maybe three inches on the side with
control buttons and then the battery was
slipped in the back
and you can catch it
there was a uh
the battery pack that i had in my pocket
that was with the coax
from the handheld section oh is that
right
cable right that came around and
attached to the top of the battery well
i always carried it in my left pocket
wow
and
i i don't know why
i'm left-handed but i've always carried
it the whole time i was in vietnam i
carried it here
and it just at that instant
saved my butt excuse me absolutely no
yeah
we're just talking here it's a little
bit of the history
of just another day in song yeah it it
it happened like that every time we went
in just about to uh on a bright light
right so at some point the second half
of the team gets pulled out
and
the two king bees with the entire team
turn around and head to
return to fob one and the fubar to get
you to the medics right and
unbeknownst
to spider parks who was flying in the
third backup helicopter the chase job
the chase chopper and in this case for
the uh again for our audience
when on a mission for an extraction to
be a lead king b because of height
heat they can only carry so many men
right and so your eight-man team they
pick up the first four the second
chopper comes in picked up the second
four
they're turning around going back
spider didn't realize he was in the
third kingby
and he didn't realize that the team had
been fully extracted he ordered the king
b the third king be down on the lz
spider
jumped out of the helicopter ran into
the bomb crater to see if anybody was
left alive
and the only person there was the dead
lieutenant that was killed in action
he gets back on the helicopter while
under extreme enemy fire as the
helicopters lifting off
the door gunner was killed
and then they all returned
to fubai
so this was
your
brief visit
to hell
yeah
on that day and
um
just you know a part that didn't get
into the book that came out at one of
our reunions years later
was the aspect of you
and you still tell it better than i do
because you were there when that story
came out how
you did pick up steve perry and put him
in the helicopter and you picked up a
second team member yeah i take it from
there because i wanted to
don't forget your little signal to our
communist friends
well
it happened after i put steve in the
chopper
they just sat down there was no other
way we had somebody had to grab him mike
and the rest of the team
was returning fire to give us cover
i picked him up
and threw him on the chopper
i think there was probably maybe 15
yards from the edge of the crater to
where they sat 15 yards
and you're carrying him and i carried
him and you had 112 pounds
plus my rucksack and all the other
garbage i didn't have too many rounds
left and the magazines were gone and
just about all my grenades were gone
you were traveling light yeah i was
traveling light then
but i picked up steve and steve was
probably maybe 145. yeah he was a lean
mean yeah
yeah yes and the reason he went with us
was because he's a medic
he had been on
the ground with idaho before
and knew some of their maneuvers
so
and he was a good medic
and so once i got him on there i turned
around
and i didn't know this until
probably five years ago
spiders said he looked
over as i turned somebody from above the
bomb crater fired around it went in my
elbow and out the hole of
one of the wounds from the grenade
and i turned around emptied my
magazine on him for your car 15. yeah my
car at the same time i flipped him off
well
i don't ever remember that but spider
witnessed it and
he had 30 some years in the military as
a command sergeant major so i'm not
doubting what he tells me no
and
i left it at that so
that's how that story went and i went
back after
our point man which was pretty much he
was a little bit lighter than me yet
and i grabbed him and started for there
and then one other
um had shrapnel wounds one other
gentleman on the team
came up with us and the rest of them
were on the second chopper
and
we took off and we did the same thing we
fired
rounds at him and everything else
and other than steve
being stunned like that and partially
paralyzed
that we uh
we had him on the on the floor
and
once he was there
then
we started returning fire out the window
and the door
and
the ship was getting hit all over the
place you can see just like
little spots of light coming through
they always they always once we got back
on a lot of missions like that they
would
uh the door gunner would go around and
take duct tape
go over the hole and then paint black
paint over them and you wouldn't
wouldn't know they were there anymore
they look like a new aircraft
[Laughter]
psyops yeah
just another way so and so from here you
go back to fubai
well we we started a touchdown and fubai
and they must have got called and said
they could fly into uh
uh
uh army
like a mass unit right
there at fubai yeah just down the
highway just down the highway right and
we landed there and
we were all steve and
the vietnamese i don't know or the
chinese we had
were
sent someplace else
and
mike
when that other chopper landed and steve
we're all put inside the unit
because that was the night then we came
down to check you to see you guys you're
all banished up by the time we get in
there right
and then um
by that time did steve get some of his
feelings back or how much longer was
that i didn't even see steve they must
have taken him some because it's
associated with a different a different
area of the mass unit to take care of
them
but they were
they were they worked on his feet
and his other shrapnel wounds
but
as for
being paralyzed i don't know what they
did right so in your case here you get
back you eventually get medevaced out so
how did all this career begin for you
for you
serving 10 years in the army where did
all this begin back in oregon ohio
george what what inspired you to get
into special forces
well we got a
uh
in the city of oregon their police
department
they had a
young officer
and i met him through the pal gym
and he was
not actually a detective but he was a
member of the oregon police force where
i went to school
and i met him through the pal program
the athletes in the police department
and
i boxed when i was younger
up until time i went in the military and
he
more or less participated working with
the young
young men you play a little football too
right i played football and played ice
hockey since i was five and
played baseball as a catcher and
played softball as an older man after
the military certainly
but
and also
wrestled in high school and captain the
wrestling team at oregon clay high
school
um
i ended up with some pretty good records
you know and i ran track and pole
vaulted so
i was in excellent condition i loved to
swim
uh i stayed healthy i ran every morning
a lot of times i had to walk home from
school because nobody
lit was in the
athletic program i was in
lived out where i did and we were eight
miles from school
no so i had to go on the route two
that ran along lake erie and hitchhike
because my dad worked second shift
so
either
if i wanted to be participating in
anything after school
i had to find my own way
or walk or run so
or all the above or all the above that
was and i did it
winter winter time because wrestling
didn't start until after football season
was over
and up there
october is a breaking line right
right along lake erie and
yeah so at some point you're talking to
this to your to this officer officer it
came down to like there's two spec ops
units that he mentioned to you special
forces and navy seals
and they had just been starting
the same navy seal program
with
the udt
instructors we're starting to train
the new instructors that were supposed
to be the seal instructor right
and
he said physically
and this officer just happened to be a
a
xsf
sergeant oh is that right yeah yeah so i
took heed what he was telling me
and then my dad and all
he never explained a whole lot of what
he did
but he served
a tremendous amount of time well your
dad was a paratrooper in world war ii
right so he was during world war ii in
korea and wow
he also was
a demo man is what he told me so
and some of the stuff other than that
that he did was
pretty similar to what we were starting
to get into you know in in the sod yes
error
and so i listened to him
and he's never steered me wrong he said
don't do what you don't feel good about
in your stomach and in your heart
so
he said you've got two choices you're an
excellent swimmer you're not afraid of
the water
he said you're an excellent physical
condition and you're no dummy
he said when you want to apply yourself
you'll be all right
and he said
whichever one you choose i'll
back you a hundred percent
and
so
he said he said sf is more overall
you'll get more training
you'll do more and you'll feel more
relaxed with the the guys that are in
there
this other program is just being started
so
you know you got to look at that you got
tradition to go into
so i would follow
the tradition and i said yeah that's
what i was planning on doing in the
first place
so
i found
a recruiter
that was an sf recruiter
and it was my junior year in high school
and i had already
received several letters from
different schools
and when i went and visited them
about wrestling
football hockey and stuff like this
they would only give me like a quarter
gram and then they found out how big i
was and they thought i was 175 pounds
and i was only 112.
and they said you're too small
so i just left it at that and i followed
the suggestion of my dad
and from that point on
it was just
nose to the grindstone yeah because of
my size
basic training they tried to say well
we don't know if you're going to make it
so you enter basic training where what
year fort knox
64.
64 ladder par 64.
and
i received time
from when i signed that
when i signed that paper
in my junior year right that was added
to my military time
because that was a commitment already
signed was that right yeah
at that time yeah yeah
and
so we
we went on from there and
um
as i went through the different areas
80 uh
my advanced
training
temperature training yeah i went through
uh
communication at fort gordon
and that's where i met
my buddy
mike tucker no yeah
and we went through
radio school together
and we come out pretty high in the class
so
they decided to send us to uh
what they called a
special messaging
center
okay
yeah
and it was no more than
special codes and the whole ball of wax
did that include morse code well
they were starting to teach it then they
were it wasn't part of the program it
was
more or less related to
um the radio teletype the standard
radios that the infantry carries and and
that that type of thing when they had to
send
top secret messages or
secret messages and that
how the codes would be broken up
and then it got a little bit into the
morse code
right
and
then from that point once we got out of
there we went to jump school
i was the last one off the bus
at fort benning
took my duffel bag
threw it out from the top step then
jumped from the top step to the ground
and
over to my left was
this drill sergeant standing there said
son you might as well get back on the
bus i said
why is that sergeant
he said you're too light you'll never
open up the chute
at 112 pounds yeah and i turned around i
looked at him and i said sir
i said i'm
nothing against you your rank or the
army
but you're full of [ __ ]
my dad was in and he's the same size i
am
and he was a paratrooper during the
second world war in korea
so
don't give me your garbage
i said i'm going through this
and when i come out of there
i went through with a
gentleman that was a mr footballer i
can't remember what state
but i burned him several times
physical fitness he couldn't stay with
me
so
i just proved him wrong there
again and of course that you had extra
attention from the
the officer that
had bad matthew at the beginning there
of course so you had that additional but
you managed through
right
it was just uh
one one person after another just said
that i was too small well
i've got my beret i'm 53 years or more
away from the sog
stuff that i've done
and
i'm still alive
i'm still small
and i still have my friends inside
and we're able to talk about it now
indeed so um
after your jump school
did you go to the traditional army first
before you went to special forces you
were able to go right up at the top i
was one of the lucky ones i think
because
i never served
in a standard army unit or standard
military unit
uh
i never did like that
i was
kind of a
kid that didn't like
authority that overused it
you know instead of just teaching them
and getting the job done
they would emboss them polish shoes
strings being tied right
metals on straight
pick up the butts that other people
smoked and threw on the ground
too lazy to walk over and put it in a
can
you know i just yeah that was a type of
authority i didn't like if you would sit
down and tell me what i'd done wrong
i'll accept it
but if you just yell at me
excuse me
the bird just went out
the bird was the word
so um
the uh
you're in
you go through special forces training
and what was your mos training there
when you got there did michael were you
and mike still a dynamic duel at that
point
we went through training group together
we went through communications together
when we graduated i figured
we'd seen the last of each other right
both of us got assigned to the sixth
group c company and sixth group was at
fort bragg at the time at four but
everybody was at fort bragg except
the first right they were in okinawa and
the tenth group was in germany germany
and batos
and
so
we get assigned to the sixth group
where they're two weeks
mike and are on the same a team
really unheard of
on
unheard of two junior radio operators on
the same team wow okay yeah yeah
so i
you know i'm talking with mike and that
and
we've been introduced on the team and
all this stuff and
i get a brilliant idea
i'm gonna ask the team sergeant
what we're gonna do because we're two
junior radio operators right wow
he tells me i i asked him i said
sergeant i said can you tell me
why they put two junior radio operators
together
he said well sergeant sternberg he said
i've already talked
and
i've got all your information from you
you and mike going through the
the communication school and everything
else and you all done very well
and uh
he said
villa rosa was my instructor so no
villarreal oh yes sergeant first class
paul villarosa
and he was somebody that i
listened to sure okay
and
so i said you know
well now that you got the report on us
you know
there's two
ranks there's a junior and a senior
radio operator on the team
[Laughter]
and he said well for being the smart one
and mike i turn around to mike mike
start smiling he said you're in trouble
george
[Laughter]
he said since you asked that question
and i know what your next question is
who does the paperwork
i'm the senior radio operator right and
make sure that all the checks are done
on all the radios
he said
question
and you sound that intelligent
guess what
you get it for the first week and mike
gets it after that and then you can
rotate
[Laughter]
so we left it at that and two weeks
later
from the heat of
north carolina which it wasn't hot in
january right
we
get sent to
fairbanks alaska for winter survival
training
i think it was 60 miles north or
somewhere up there where it was colder
than hell
wow and he uh when we come back we were
up there six weeks come back and
when we got back we were with them two
two more weeks and then they transferred
mike and i again
the dynamic duo we went to third group
no
we were together on the same a team
c company she comes in a third group
and we were with them for quite a while
and then we left
and were reassigned to fifth group
and we had done something
with the third group that
i still don't know if they're going to
talk about
so we'll leave it at that
and
then
we're assigned to the fifth group
so we get there so by that time was
fifth group in the triangle wow they
were yeah they were already there okay
so
getting back to
a calendar here so it's been 1967 now
yeah you and mike are back to third
group
now they're saying the good news is
gentlemen you two are going to netrank
fifth grade we're going to fifth group
vietnam
and then report you report it there when
did you mike go over together yep oh my
god
yeah we were vietnam survived yeah yeah
and uh
so we ended up
uh
in the train
we get there and
the number of replacements i can't
remember but there was enough of them
yeah
because let me just to get back there's
just a little thing from the book here i
want to get back to because there's
another aspect of your history with
fifth group
in vietnam
that makes you another added unique
personality and part of our sog legends
um
uh by the time that that bright light
came up that we talked about earlier
you and mike both had enough experience
together that you respected each other
enough that you could beat a one zero
which in sog a one zero is a team leader
one one's assistant team leader one two
is the radio operator right so in this
case you two would flip back and forth
right and
um
on several missions
you and mike
and i forget what recon team was you ran
missions out of fob three at caisson
this is night by this time is like 1967
the beginning of 68
when
the national headlines in america and
around the world was the siege of
caisson
before and after the tet offensive which
was at the end of january 68
and all the attention in the media
was the marine corps
and the air power directed against the
nba who were trying to overrun the
caisson base but
what got no attention in the top secret
world was fob3 and you could talk a
little bit about that but i just want to
get back to
one more
key point
and
together on str oregon
both men respected each other's prowess
in the field
so much that they rotated 1-0 duty with
strong results
they meaning you and mike
were among the first to photograph
nba bulldozer trails cutting swaths
through triple canopy jungle
to expand the ho chi minh trail complex
they photographed
the tanks including one shot where the
nva star was visible
and prior to that
this is prior to the nva attacking the a
camp a 101 at lang bay which again was
at the end of 1968 january
yeah and
um
at one mission
you all had captured an nva pow
you're flying back to fob1 in a kingby
when one of the team members discovered
that the p.o.w was a woman
sternberg and the team member holding
the pow
were so startled
that they loosened their grip
momentarily
the woman
bolted
from the h-34 and jump to her death
i mean that gives our listeners a little
bit of an impression of the dedication
of
those soldiers
the enemy
the propaganda used on their soldiers
was so intense
that
um
the tactics that the north used
to keep their soldiers in line
and that i would have to say it was
inhumane
it would be a tactic used
in
back through history
where
the so-called leaders of the country
would
threaten that person
and
the threats would be if you don't serve
us
we'll take your family out and when they
said take your family out
that meant
all the way from your aunts your uncles
any kind of kin that they could find
that was related to you
and they would kill them
okay yeah they meant
anything right okay
and it would put a disgrace on your name
wow
i think the use of
drugs and different things like that
also
would entice them you know
they'd get to a state where
they weren't in control of their own
thoughts or their bodies right so like
you're in that bomb crater here they
come you hit them two or three times
and they still move forward because
they're obviously drugged or high on
something right and
when you're looking when you look in a
person's eyes and they're
10 12 feet from you
and they're holding a weapon and a
grenade
and you know
that if anybody else took the number of
shots and where the shots were taken
from a weapon
in the chest the stomach the head
whatever
that
the body would stop
instantly while the body don't stop
the forward motion and drive in that
person's mind and then the muscles that
it's reacting to
is right now it continues to move
and
um with that thought in mind
when a person holding a grenade
and they're moving forward
and they finally release it
they could be already
dead you know
but their motions carrying them
and that's how a lot of us got hurt in
that bomb crater and they're dead before
they hit the ground but still before
they hit the ground and i've been to
several
a1
reunions
in sevierville at the tennessee
aviation center where they have one of
the
remaining few a1s one skybraider tail
number six six five or six five five six
five five indeed yeah yes
and uh it still operates i still operate
and it flew missions supporting sog
teams
during the sequel war right and uh
i've talked with several of their pilots
and
a lot of their pilots remember
some of that stuff
that my team did
you know absolutely so
they had to they didn't know the team
names
but they can remember the mission well
and then the same thing would be true
for us the icon teams that were on the
ground we didn't know the names of the
pilots that came in no and i over these
years of them coming to our reunion and
joining our organization
and us going to them i've met several of
them right and that organization we're
speaking of is the special operations
association that was formed in 1976
by sag recon man
and then it was a span of the hatchet
force and then the helicopter pilots and
then to them and then the a1 and we've
welcomed other
other uh assets in they're welcome to
join because they supported sog right
and we're live today thanks to their
heroism and aviation skills
those a1 pilots and them phantom pilots
and the gun ships
and extraction ships
um and are especially our king bee oh
yeah pilots and door gunners
without them
i would have to say that 90 90 of us
would be dead today we'd be fertilizer
yes we'd be fertilizer regrown and
spread out a couple hundred times
already so let me take you back now to
pre
um
pre-may when you're actually running
missions out of caisson on that one
mission we took the photographs that
proved
their nva tanks were there
and this is 1968 and the end of 67
and no tanks the communists had not used
tanks anywhere in the war
and there had been rumors
but you had direct evidence and proof
so from there when you did like when the
recon team would come back to base
they would bring you into
s2
you would get debriefed the s3 people
want to know anything about
anti-aircraft sightings anything new
tactics on the ground
and then
you would go back clean up feed the team
and get ready to go but in this case
something else happened
people didn't quite believe what you all
were saying so no at some point
what happened that was so different to
you and mike on this one mission
and this was like around december early
part of january of 68 january 68 just
before
um approximately two weeks before they
hit long
yeah
and uh mike and i
didn't get back together they separated
us
first of all you do the mission you come
back you do your you after you after
actually debriefing at the camp and then
this is that food by now that would be
one then they separated you no or down
south what they did is when we faced
came in the country yeah
they had us together and when we came
back from the mission
no when when we
went
from
netra uh natrang to
um
our camps right we were issued to
mike got off the king bee at fubai
they sent me to kaesong json oh
so
once i got the case on
everything you know we knew that people
were moving around right you could hear
them and so could we just do a little
sidebar here just for people who've
never heard the word caisson
how significant that was because that
seized went on for several months
every day you had artillery coming in
rockets
and there was always activity outside
the base mortars
and we lost men there and men who were
seriously injured just from all the
artillery and meanwhile
you
and your recon teams other sog teams
were running missions across the fence
right from that base
that day that we
um
so you're in case on now right i'm in
case on my 1-0 is john mcgovern at the
time
and
uh the third american was joe conlon
j.a pigpen right an e-6 and an e-7 right
we go out and we're supposed to observe
what's going on on the other side of the
river yeah so we head out in a direction
towards car rock mountain which was very
distinct
you could see it from
casino and for our viewers tell them why
there is an additional unique aspect to
korok which was dominated by the north
vietnamese army right they had guns
and guns that could come out on tracks
fire on the base and then retract
retract before the fighters could get in
there
and
they could throw everything in
on the place and it's not gonna move it
might take a couple chips off the
outside
because i think that
mountain was made out of granite
the rock in it was granite yeah they
were able to carve through it do all
this fancy stuff over the years
and i still swore
that the guns that they had inside were
sitting on tracks
that were pulled up there after they
were loaded
and the recoil would take them back down
and they'd reload them and then bring
them back up
and i thought they were as big as the
ones that hitler had on railroad cars
you know i mean it's very possible but
it was a huge round whatever it was like
i said it was a 157 possibly oh it was
big yeah it was but you could hear it
whistling if it went by you right
and i guess at one point caisson was
taking
uh around 1500 rounds a day a day
and
i was there from
december
to april or from actually from august
to april
of
67 68 and 68
in april
is when they shipped me
to fubai right
and mike and i started running the
minute i walked in the gate mike said
you and me are together he knew i was
coming for some reason
and so that's
where oregon got tied up before i was
with the brew team
john mcgovern joe conlon
and there were several other so get back
to that mission then could you take the
photography we went out for observation
mcgovern was the 1-0 mcgovern 1-0 i was
a radio operator joe conlon was a
one-two okay very good okay yeah and
on our way back we always
radioed ahead to inform
the team
that was the a team that was in camp 101
at long bay
that they would have a team in their
area
okay
and uh so
we stayed outside
of their
kill zone
and sf camps
had the inner wire outer wire
minefields in the wire
and then they had a clean area
sometimes went out 300 yards to 400
yards is what they tried to clear
so it would be open view to all of their
firing area
so they wouldn't get any closer than
that right well
as we're moving through the brush as we
were moving through the brush and that
and
i spotted something
and i said wait a minute so
i said joe take this camera
i had the camera also
and he took
we had um
pentax and
uh
yeah
and he uh
he took the camera and he says what's up
i said look at this
and you could see a track going
in the brush
and i seen branches broke on a couple
different trees
and i said this isn't right
so i start taking pictures of it
and i use my hands
and i use the butt an extended portion
with a cost extended stock on the car
15.
those are all positive measurements
okay
they can understand what i was referring
to by that i give them the the width
between the tracks
the height at which the weeds and
branches on
smaller bushes were broke which would
give them the height from
the height from the
ground to the bottom of the tank right
or tracked vehicle whatever
and then
i give them the outside
dimension with so many
photos of me using the weapon so you
came to a conclusion there was a tank
that was a tank it had to be you could
see where
the turret had swung around and broke
branches off at a certain height
so i used my weapon on that tree and
right you know to me
that's what i used in in the report sure
well it wasn't
i don't know maybe by the time saigon
got it down at sag headquarters
they said okay it's time to call this
team down there was only about three
days
we were still in duty dirty uniforms at
that time because all the
garbage being fired into the camp yeah
well
at that at that point we
we knew that the three of us were gonna
have to go down so
we had a king bee come in the morning we
got on it
went down there
carrying our weapons
i don't go anywhere
in a war zone without a weapon i don't
care who you are yeah and
so we went to the trying they flew us
out in the trang to saigon
and once we got down there we had an e6
out there on guard duty
tell us we couldn't head quarters sog
headquarters couldn't take the weapons
and i said sorry sorry i don't go
anywhere without a weapon and besides
that it's loaded
yeah so all i have to do is flip that
switch and you're ready to rock and roll
we're down here for
information
so whoever your boss is you better get
him out here because
we ain't going anywhere without these
weapons
my
team star my team leader 1-0 john
mcgovern just
pats me on the shoulder
at that point i had a point i had a
feeling in my system that i've had
enough of
authority at that point
so i
we went inside
e7 said you gotta leave your weapon sir
said sorry sarge
i don't go anywhere i'll take the round
out of the chamber
but the magazine stays in it
does it compromise the accepted yeah
yeah that's what i'll take the round out
of the chamber
and i'll leave it on
safe
but the magazine stays in it and i've
got the round in my hand and the rest of
them in the magazine
we went in we
sat down
sergeant that was in charge of that area
said uh
the panel will be in in a minute you can
talk to them
while they came in there was a
air force colonel
army colonel
moraine colonel
and then there was a
a one-star general i'm almost sure it
was i can't remember who
all of them but
first one to talk a lot of brass a lot
of brass
you got their attention with your
after-action report reporting the
possibility of
tanks the intel department had questions
so they wouldn't call us down there
unless they did
and the way i described it so
we get down there we got no markings on
our uniform no id saying who the hell we
were
or
identifying marks no rank no nothing
and
so
first questions out of the
and why they had the marine colonel
there
beyond me had no business in there
and
his first questions were
who took the photos
well
john
took his hand pointed like that at me
i said okay
what is your
question again
and the girl said
who took the pictures
i said
all the photos in there
that depict
my hands
and my arms
and me holding the weapon
were taken
by this gentleman
and i point it to joe joe yeah
and
he said
who
made the determination
on
the way you referred to the measurements
i said i did
because
i'm
so many years old
and my hands are not going to change i'm
five four hundred and twelve pounds
that isn't going to change
so
they're a positive measurement within
fractions of an inch
and he says okay
tell me what you think this is
and it was one of the photographs i took
and then describing
the distance between
the inside measurement between the
tracks
and the height
at which the bottom of the vehicle would
have been right in comparison to the
ground
and he said how did you determine that i
said with
the rifle
my hands and the extension
of the stock on the car 15.
so the bottom line was he wasn't
believing the fact that right you felt
what i determined
in our discussion to that point is that
he wasn't going to believe anything we
said
so i just let him go on with his
question he said
can you be positive
that those are your pictures i said yes
them on my hands see that one's got a
kink going this way this way and that's
from me playing football getting my
hands stepped on by cleats and
fighting when i was
boxing and and hockey
oh okay
well
from what we determine i said
what
all of you is determined or you
determined
he said well what i determined
was that
i don't think that you guys seen tank
tracks i said okay
are you a governing factor
in this panel
and he said one of them
i said why
and he said i'm a full bird colonel i
said yeah but you're in the marine corps
you guys are you guys operate totally
different than what we do
and if you think
that i'm going out there
to build stories up
that's not the reason why i went into
special forces
oh
i went in to do my job with the
best and if i don't expect anything less
of me than what i expected the members
around me
of that community
and if you don't believe me
why am i down here
right okay sure
we're getting there
and that's the first time that they ever
brought you down the sidewalk right
right
and i said
if you don't believe us out in the woods
or jungle like we are
then you probably don't even believe
your men
that are in the core
and he said well was that a remark
against me i said well you can take
whatever you want to
if you don't believe me i'm out there
with
five
indige
and normally two americans now we got a
little bit bigger team with three
americans and eight in dig
and you're still not believing me
i said
you have
people in the core
that go out in platoons
companies battalions
we're operating with anywhere from 10
to
5. and
when you start questioning me
that means that you question them
and that's not a good idea you got to
start listening to the people that are
out in the field people that are on the
ground the people that are on the ground
i'm not doing it for my health i can
tell you that much
when you're outnumbered ten to one or a
hundred to one
you're not in a favorable situation
and i don't want that camp in there
because i know people in that camp
and i don't want them hurt
nobody else in the panel said anything
he said well
i'll have to say that i don't believe a
word you're saying
i don't believe the pictures i said you
know what
i don't really give a [ __ ] what you
think
and
how you got on this
panel is beyond me or what you're even
doing in this building
from that point on
you can think whatever you want to me
about me
but i got no respect for you as an
individual your rank yeah the core yes i
got several friends in it but as for you
you're a jerk
and
that's when
the lead man in the panel said okay
we're all gonna break up here you four
go in that room come over and talk to
you all right because so
after all that's done
then uh let's fast forward because we've
had other interviews or personal contact
with one of the men that served at lang
bay
and
when we talked to them
paul longrear
was a first lieutenant then retired as a
colonel highly respected he was there
when they got hit by tanks
and
subsequently we've talked to paul and he
said we never had
any intel reports
that from
sf said we were told that the air force
had
reports of suspicions about tanks
so this is an air force
report that could be
could be credible or not had they told
us at our green beret camp at lang bay
a101
that
the photographs
taken
were by sf men because i don't think
the traditional a camp man knew that sag
existed they didn't know we had green
berets across the fence
that was
so top secret
compartmentalization said had we known
those were green boys that said we saw
this
that would have made a world of
difference
but they didn't so
that's just one of those episodes that
you're a part of that show
where there's an inclination by
higher-ups
in buildings far away from the
battlefield
make command decisions and judgments not
based on facts but opinions so you were
a victim of that eventually you returned
a case on
where your team with mcgovern ran other
missions
and then you get the fob-1 mike tucker
you do your historic bright light
but then after that you and mike still
ran a few more missions oh we ran quite
a few more missions you did and
if you just go back to a couple of your
more memorable ones during your sog time
we uh
we got called out on several bright
lights and
we also had our regular missions
and just on one of our regular missions
we
we ran a ridge top
this is in laos now this is in laos and
uh we ran the ridge top
and one side
we were would have been the
because ash i'll run
kind of
north
west to southeast right
and we were on the
east side on the ridge and we could
actually see the road from the top of
the ridge
going right down the air
sure
and
we got all kinds of noise
around us okay close to the team close
to the team we're i i would have to say
that
they were using the bamboo
the tractors would four corner you
and when you heard the first
beat of those sticks
they were boxing your team
and
then if you heard them again
the box would become smaller oh is that
right they they
seem to close in yeah which means they
knew
pretty much were you and you had to
you had to find a way out
and usually
you had to move now not
a couple seconds later
or a minute it's had to be now no time
for a tea break you had to get up you
have that now so
we would take our chances
and head for the middle
of one of those
legs of that and well trying to keep the
high ground advantage if possible we
wanted the high ground because that side
was a safe side for us sure
well we ended up hanging
off of a cliff
with our
we usually had 25 foot lanyards and uh
like a swiss seat yeah six foot piece of
rope right and then we would have a uh
another clip that we could clip on and
and stay on the rope
that we had around a tree or a rock or
whatever
and we suspended ourselves over the side
and covered it up and our whole team
was on the side and we were there all
night
and i'll tell you what
trying to
get up before daylight once they moved
out they never even seen us
never
did you hear them move past
they moved past because they couldn't
find any tracks right you know sure
and
we never file
as long as i mike and i were together
never followed a trail
we would be one side of it or not
and we would try to
intermittent side steps
and
[Music]
we were so light really sometimes i
think we were above the ground
so
somebody was watching over us
but once we got up it was hard to move
your legs
you know being i don't know might have
been
10 11 o'clock at night or something like
that when we were up there
i was still able to make radio contact
at midnight you know but make sure to
um
not do it when they were
right close
so
that's how that happened but we were
able to
stay in for a while and
able to make some photographs
some intel reports from traffic in the
valley traffic in the valley and
by that time once we started airborne
and out of the area yeah and just be
just for a point of reference the ashaw
valley
throughout the vietnam war and i-corps
was the most
dangerous area we had more green berets
killed they're more teams hit either
wiped out or severely
um
injured and
so you're in one of the worst target
areas
and there have been there have been
teams in
there and what they would do would be
change the lettering and the numbers of
the target targets but you would say
well
when you look on the map
when the coordinates come out
you would know that that was the same
target that three teams before that were
in and two of them were all shut up and
one's missing
so
they were using
trying to get real information
out of that area
and they didn't know
sooner or later somebody was going to
pick that up
that they were changing the numbers and
oh yeah because the team used to talk
amongst themselves a little bit right
when you come back you definitely talk
to the
other teams
so that
that's just some of the hairy stuff
and so
um
when does your tour of duty in sog wrap
up do you and mike wrap up together yeah
and then from there we want to talk
about the remaining of your 10 years in
the army wow kind of
go through it
at
different times mike and i would
talk and
say well are you
are we going to extend over here
are we going to go home
well we get to that point and then they
call a team on a bright light or
or a uh
we'd get bda for a bomb damage
assessment
or go in and try to photograph this or
pick up some sounding devices
and that yeah did you ever insert those
air force uh sounding devices
yeah yeah because those are three units
they had a central unit with the coaxial
cables that went out right and you had
to put them next to a trail and we had
put one in the [ __ ] do you remember
where you put yours
but anyways you put it in right and
that's still
a hairy mystery because you go into an
enemy territory now you are on the trail
right next to the trail putting these
things in so you can have any enemy any
time while the
air force used to drop
the air force used to drop
stuff that would land in the
in the jungle right
and
you would have to
look they give you a coordinate
and you'd have to locate where it was at
well
don't sound it
right
those sounding devices yeah
would pick up the motor sounds uh
if several people walked by they could
tell how many people and
all this technical stuff that i didn't
get into right
and
but so let me get this straight this is
the first i heard about this kind of a
mission where the air force drops the
sensors and now they say oh
spike team oregon go find them to see
how they're working well no we had to
pick them up we were supposed to bring
them back they were actually devices
that
i'm trying to remember how they uh
how they uh how they operated but uh
well they would have radio frequencies
and once they're put in they could pick
up the sensors in the air force and come
by a monitor
or hillsboro will come by and get the
intel off these right but they could
only leave them in for so long yeah they
didn't want to leave them in there then
they knew that
people would pick them up and trace them
back and then now they got
information that the u.s is in there and
then it becomes a big political
yeah they see that made in usa tag on it
sensors or layouts or a bunch of the
first clue a bunch of serial numbers you
know made by dupont or whatever right
well
that kind of stuff went on all the time
so you actually got in you actually
found one you brought it back and turned
it over to them and of course the air
force and the cia all said hey thanks
george yeah
well that we didn't get to see them but
that went down to the chain of command
but uh and again on a routine mission
like that even when you leave the ao
you're under fire oh
on that one
uh we ended up taking fire on the
insert on the insert oh god more so on
the
extraction yeah
and the door gunner got
hit okay yeah it hit him right across
here well
i got a
cravat and a
pressure bandage on it
and
mike
took him at that time we only had uh
three
five
we had six of us and we were all on the
chopper under one shop yeah
and
so mike took him held the cravat on and
i took the door gun over
and
50 some years later
john was at the
thing and we received awards and i got a
air medal with a v
which was the second one i got
and
you know
that's something sog didn't get
right you know i mean air metals just
for our listening audience or viewing
audience an air metal is awarded after
you accumulate a certain number of hours
on combat missions you have to keep a
log turn the log in at the certain
number i forget what the exact rounds
are so that's for a traditional air
metal which
there are helicopter pilots that would
have 60 70 because they flew so many
missions now
the difference here
is that you get the air metal with a v
device
v as in valor
and in this case you earned that because
you took over the door gunner slot after
he gets wounded you patch him up and go
to a sturdy caliber during the
extraction right and uh
ben said we had little
nicks and that stuff from yeah
just normal shrapnel fire
and uh how many purple hearts did you
get
well
as of today i think i got six
that's all
that's it
but you know a lot of them
a lot of them we wouldn't
nobody would even turn in you would go
to another dance
right yeah they
if you needed a couple stitches they'd
put a couple stitches in if you needed
uh
medication or disinfectant or something
like that they would take care of that
but it was our medics yeah the green
brain medicine right and nobody in the
world nobody expected anything right you
know
and down the road you didn't even think
about it beings a lot of operators out
of sod recon teams were young guys
they didn't think anything about metals
like i said there's
i've gotten several medals in the last
in the five years that they were
awarding them to us back
five to eight years ago well this is
again we're talking about the special
operations association where they worked
with
government officials
on
people like yourself
who had served on missions
and the
uh went back
thanks to people at the soa and and
members as well as um
a couple national guard people uh one
neil neil thorne comes to mind
and we had a couple other people
that i'm not naming right now but they
went back went to congress to senators
got the awards and then at our reunion
they were awarded people like yourself
tony harrell
big pen
were getting awards that everything that
went from a silver star
down to an accommodation medal for valor
or your air medal with valor yeah and
that was what we're speaking of here
which again
it was awards earned in combat
but again never received never received
military service during during the time
we're in
and a lot of times the uh
the s1 shots which are awards and
decorations is one of their functions
they're busy and or our people like
purple hearts she tried to stay away
from her purple heart it didn't do you
any good didn't do anything
but that was again that's the that's the
mindset
uh nobody joined sog to obtain medals
they had a mission we were there to do
the mission the quiet professional
tradition
to move on i think
i think everybody that operated
out of sag
that ran recon
and understood the severity of what
we could bring to the table
even though sometimes we thought we were
young
used out there as a piece of meat on a
string
well
run that'll run that out a little bit
because um
i think that
um
when you and i we've been in it
we've we've heard this expression but
when you say it that way
take a little step further so
you're to meet
sog headquarters says piece of meat
which in this case would be rt or st
oregon
go to target s3 or whatever would be
you're in the target and the reason why
you feel like you're a little bit of a
piece of meat is because
well
we'd get in there
and there'd be
gunfire already
and you're 1500 feet off the ground
and all of a sudden you see a bunch of
little bright lights like stars lighting
up in the helicopter where it comes
round's coming through
or take out a hydraulic line you'd have
oil all over the floor
and you know you just felt like you were
uh
raw meat out there as uh
to draw everybody out well when
everybody come out next thing you know
here was the air assets
and after you left
here come a wing of b52s in there on a
uh arc light and just arc light the
whole area and arc lights pretty heavy
damage an arc light is a b-52 strike
that would come in immediately after the
team or as close after the team left the
area of operations because there was so
much enemy activity that the air force
and the intel people in saigon thought
it was worth coming back so then you're
the meat
the nva comes to you
they attack you and by only by the grace
of the lord and heroic aviators
your team gets out
the nva are heavy clustered in that area
the b-52s come in
and then sometimes did you have to do a
bomb damage assessment and that would be
after the b-52s come in
then the air force goes hey could you
guys go out and check out the sea
do us a give us a head count how many
people did we kill or something like
that you'd get close enough to
maybe get some kind of approximate and
what
equipment was damaged and that right if
you told them
track vehicles and stuff like this you
know you know that they would just shake
their head and said yeah they don't have
any track vehicles right
you know you'd see a
couple dozen jeeps or a bunch of well
and also with the with the bda
we were told hey
no we just hit it with a b-52 strike the
enemy's gonna be
dead or they'll be walking around like
zombies because there's they're so
stunned
well the truth of the matter is when a
recon team got into an area where you're
doing a bomb damage assessment the truth
of the matter is the soldiers the enemy
soldiers are indeed alive and they're
not happy
right yeah
they're not happy at all
believe me yeah and uh vengeance they
want some vengeance right
and
that's usually when
you get fire from all over the place
there might be a
a company down here and
in our
u.s military a company was approximately
250 men
there'd be a company here there might be
two companies over here
you know they'd be scattered out but
you'd you'd be walking into a battalion
or bigger right and again for our our
viewers
um with sog missions when a recon team
went across the fence we had no
traditional support from conventional
units
no artillery
and
no unit could come and wretch you we did
have the best air force in the world
and we did have outstanding army gun
ships and of course the heroic
yes and the the slicks or the king bees
right that was a vital support element
so when you went across the fence you
were there you had to you had to make
the call though to be extracted and you
had to make the call that you needed
support right and sometimes you would
after being in a tactical situation like
you'd hear the enemy closing in on you
and you would say
i want a tactical extraction
meaning you wanted to be distracted
because you knew danger was approaching
so rather than get involved in a
firefight we can report the enemies here
or we've seen pictures of the trails
there pull us out we'll come back we'll
do another mission another day
there we go
a request denied
right oh yeah break contact continue
mission right which would be the most
dreaded words on any team and also
usually those words would be uttered by
an officer somewhere
flying far away in a command to control
aircraft that's not on the ground with
you or somebody at headquarters who
would say uh request tonight break
contact continue mission without
realizing
what exactly you the recon man on the
ground is up against yeah that
i majority of the time they didn't have
um the knowledge of the size
of the groups
that were hitting our recon teams
when we would get located and they'd
finally have our position
the size and numbers were just
astronomical you know and
after
being away from it for all these years
and that
um
when i think about it
i just say what the hell was i doing
you know
but
i know it had to be done
and i think that
with
the group of people we had and the
dedication
to what they were doing
is the only reason
that a majority of us
are left and what's left isn't very many
and
i've talked with several people i talked
with john meyer tilt and
major general eldon bargewell and
the frenchman and doug the frenchman
which is a personal friend of mine and
uh
you know different people like this had
actually done it
okay
to be on a recon team and to
get to that point and stay alive and
discuss the number of people that done
it over those years
you're finding men that did it two times
three times
and if you start adding that up we tried
to
get with a
historian and a member
that did a lot of research
steve sherman that
it wasn't very many that were on the
ground
you're probably looking at 500 maybe
yeah i think the numbers if just for
again for our audience that might be
listening for the first time during the
entire vietnam war we had 3.2 million
americans that served including 500 000
sailors that would be off coast that
would come in for leave
and out of that approximately 20 000
were green berets that were in country
running traditional a camps which was
highly dangerous duty a lot of the
borders right on the border like lang
bay yeah
and so this is we're not talking about
uh having tea and crumpets for lunch no
this was dangerous duty every day and
again they would hit you when they
wanted to hear you so those are our
traditional a camps then getting to sog
the men that volunteered to be about 2
000
out of 2000 approximately depending who
you talk to four to six or seven hundred
men green berets that went across
defense
and running recon and the sidebar to
this to today the element the number
that's still very heavy in every sog
recon man's heart
is that there are 50
green berets from the secret war
like glen lane robert owen others that
are still listed as missing in action
that our government's trying to work
with the
remains returned
and over 100 aviators that died
supporting us army air force south
vietnamese right and a marine corps
because we had scarface and other marine
units that rotated through that
supported our missions across the fence
right there were heroic aviation skills
unquestioned and we're live you and i
are alive today
thanks to that
fearless those aviators and again a
little bit of luck
from the recon guys that enabled us to
get out so with that thought in mind
uh wrap up the last few years of your
army experience and again you were with
special forces right i stayed with
special forces until my
my dad started getting sick in
in 72
and i still had five brothers and
sisters right at home and you're the
oldest
junior high in high school you were the
oldest in your family i was the oldest
in the family and
they all had to go
finish out their education before they
could go on anywhere well my mom
couldn't make enough money
my dad being sick off and on
he worked for general motors after got
out of the military and was a tulane
dime maker
but then
you know when he passed
i talked with the sergeant major in the
fifth group the returning
people from vietnam
had a
a group that were at bragg
that were they were trying to place or
send back or whatever but stay with that
self
and if you were a sog member
they try to keep you together
and then
if you wanted to go back you just went
back
you know
but a lot of the after that
you know i make a couple trips back and
forth to ohio every couple months to see
how my dad was doing this is while
you're at fort bragg with third group
again no with i was still with the fifth
group in the returning
okay you know
and i pulled duty we were on mike and i
were on a
committee that they had started to set
up
the new commando school yeah and we kept
getting stuffed by
by the upper brass
from
like 82nd 100 for no no we got recondo
schools we don't need special forces to
have their own
stuff while they were trying to get rid
of us any house right
well that that's not that's a whole
different story there
and that could go lead into a lot of
headaches
but uh so you're in until
73 years after your father passed away
my dad passed away in in 73 right
and
then after that
i ended up
uh going back home with so when you get
out i mean how many years of service
have you already had at that point you
were and he said at least no at that
point was at least uh nine
by by the time my dad got sick because
as a junior we got credit for when we
signed up once you put your name on that
thing
you've committed to the military sure
and as long as you kept your grades up
in your physical condition you're going
to get in sf but they're going to screen
you again
okay yeah they're going to go through
that process again
and i was lucky enough one of the lucker
guys that
i came in i never had to serve
in any other
branch other than special forces
that's why i say that
when you start going in and doing what
you kids nowadays call black ops
this is the real thing
indeed and it's no game
if you think you're going to get by
by
sleeping on duty or not listening to an
instructor
you're nuts you're going to die
if you're good enough to make it
but believe me that group of guys
that are in that special operations unit
or in special forces in general
at the time i was in
were
meant to be there at that time they were
that good
and even though a lot of them were
killed
it it is a special group
and the camaraderie is by far
more than i've seen in any organization
i belong to indeed and i've been in
several fire departments
arson
investigation baseball hockey football
so listen you could do a little bit of
that so after 10 years
you you served 10 years and when you got
out of the army what was your rank
uh i was
actually
could have been carrying a sergeant
first class stripes wow
but
when i got out i had already made it
through the process
and
done everything i had to do donald
review boards right so you were e8
eligible
all right was it eligible promotable
there we go but i knew it was going to
take at least a year or more right even
thinking about it
and
then you had to prove yourself again
okay
but that didn't bother me
and
when i got out i went home
i spent the rest of my
time
volunteer on a volunteer fire department
ocean investigator
um county investigator
uh and you also had had union skills
yeah i was a carpenter for almost 40
years
and uh
i retired at the age of 60 and said
that's it
and then after arguing with the va for
17 years
that my knees were bad
and having social security grant me
i had bad knees
then
the va came around and believed them
and i got two new knees in 2008. you
walk better now than you did in vietnam
oh yeah yeah no not really yeah i mean
sometimes
sometimes i remember watching you never
mind i'm sorry go ahead
but
yeah that was uh
that was a trip arguing with them indeed
but i've got it now
sure i dream about stuff that happened
and that's all i dream about is that
right yeah all right that was that's
part of my
ptsd sure problem
i'm not violent with anybody
but i hate stupid loud mouse
so as you wrap up here you and sally
your sweetheart today
and you live in where and how many
grandchildren great grand are you up to
the great great grandchildren yet i know
you got great great grandchildren yeah
yeah yeah we've got uh
between there's a head count here
between us we had nine
children right three are mine six or
hers
[Music]
uh
we were never married
and
but you're living happily ever after
yeah she's a great cook
we got uh
21 grandchildren
and
i'm almost positive i can't tell anymore
i'm just trying to remember names
and birthdates but we're
got uh
18 or 19 great-grandchildren you got one
in the oven right
no why well yeah there are several that
are possible
but we'll leave it at that because at
any given time it can go
indeed so this is
a you return your back up in oregon ohio
a member of strt oregon
and uh as we wrap up here we come down
to the final uh
part of our our first sog cast
anything additional you'd like to add at
this point
just as a final thought from you sir
um
i think the
men of sf whether it be nowadays or not
are
put in situations
that
could be
eliminated if
the information they get from
other sf or
people that are sent out on special
assignments
start believing
what they say
and if it's an intel type
situation
they're not out there for their health
they're out there to bring
strength to what they're trying to
accomplish
and
when you start believing in the people
that are
out there doing this
you're going to have total
better results
you're going to have people that are
going to want to
be part of it and it won't be just down
to a few
you'll have
the success of a lot of people with a
lot of knowledge that'll do that and
bring the information back to you
but you got to start believing them
and and believe me
you got the best
and there's no question in my mind about
that
all right well again george we thank you
for coming in today for our first saw
cast
and uh we're sitting here
we want to thank jaco and his right-hand
uh technical assistant echo charles
who gave us a top secret assistant here
that's joined us today to make this
podcast
possible
again
we were reading earlier from across the
fence which was the first book i put out
there's a couple other books that i had
you can go to our website with sock
chronicles
and go to amazon.com there are other sog
books that are coming out lim blacks
we have a
whiskey tango foxtrot
and the nick brockhouse has done wii fu
and jason hardy has done a series of um
sog recon books
and uh
so with amazon now they're beginning to
publicize and run more of these books
and then also
again to thank our primary sponsor jaco
and echo for getting us here today
and if you go to his podcast
these are the whole social network of
things going and of course books
ex and
he has the echelon front leadership
training and even under his books the
leadership strategy and tactics
when that book came out
uh last year
we were up in la
and they had a tremendous response a
full house and they talked about
discipline
and that even impacted my stepson ryan
at the time greatly
and it will be for
grateful for echo doing that
we are all available on social media uh
if you go to instagram account for
myself would be jstriker mart initial
jay
facebook saw chronicles
echo
and jocko are both there if you go to
at echo charles or at jocko willink
who of course served two tours of duty
in in iraq with navy seals he was the
officer in charge
at the ramadi
for a task force bruiser
and um
we are thankful for that we will return
again soon with our next second saw cast
where our scheduled guest will be jim
shorten jones who ran missions out of
ccc
and before he joined sog he served a
tour of duty with the navy after sog he
served a tour of duty with air force
reserve
as a
power rescue man pj
where he has amazing stories but the
most amazing thing about jim
that we're looking forward to sharing
with the viewers will be he's the only
man i know service member
who out of his own pocket returned
to the sag area of operations
to complete an attempt to complete a
bright light mission his recon team went
in got shot out
and we will come back with his full
story
and that'll be sodcast too and we're
presently lining up more interviews of
our sog members
and with that we'll sign off with the
traditional
jocko sign-off where we
are grateful for members like you george
and all our service members today who
serve to keep our country free
we thank our first responders border
patrol
particularly during these difficult
times
all of our law enforcement agencies
and then any first responders and during
the cobra virus
even the people at the hospitals that
are helping our people
to our country to move forward
and to come back
so with that we will close
thank you
god bless america we'll be back with
sodcast another day